[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 204 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mark and I'm here without a co-host
which means no adult supervision which
means things are gonna get wild actually
I think we'll keep things pretty even
keel and I'll just kind of stick to the
same format first up I am happy to say
that we are interviewing Ray saying a
developer advocate at Google and we're
gonna be talking a lot more about Java
Java is you know obviously a programming
language that many people are familiar
with but I was super interested in
hearing what you can use in Google cloud
with Java and Ray goes over kind of the
details for an end-to-end Java
experience right from all the way from
kind of writing code to deploying and
testing and monitoring so it was a
really great conversation and definitely
looking forward to going to the main
content but I also want to talk about a
question of the week that we'll have
coming up which I will ask and then
answer myself which talks a little bit
more about building a docker file with
Java we'll talk about using Jeb ray and
I talked about that a little bit as well
before we get into those let's talk
about some cool things of the week
[Applause]
so our first cool thing of the week is
that cloud run is cloud run is generally
available for everybody which is super
awesome because I'm sure you've heard a
lot about cloud run and it's just been a
really cool product and people have been
really excited to use it and now that
it's generally available you know we'll
see businesses try to baby adopt that a
little bit more and be a little bit more
friendly about experimenting with it
it's a super super cool you're able to
take a container and kind of just run it
so you built on K native and actually
last week's podcast episode talked a lot
more about cloud run so if you didn't
get a chance to listen to that one
definitely go recommend checking it out
otherwise go try it out for yourself and
see what cool things you can host
there's lots and lots of lots of
opportunities there the other cool thing
I would like to mention is that there's
a budget API that's now available in
beta now this one lets you build and
kind of manage your budgets from a
programmatic standpoint the reason
that's really important is because when
you're setting up a budget I think I
talked about this a couple episodes ago
but what you really want to do is set up
budgets around your projects to make
sure that you're not spending in areas
that you know you didn't plan to spend
on whether that's a product you didn't
plan to use or whether it's just kind of
keeping a cap on your dev environment
but now that the budget API is available
in beta you can start to integrate it
with your infrastructure management
right so if you're using terraform or
something like that to kind of make sure
that you have easy to reproduce and easy
to control and source coded
configuration now you can include your
budgets in that so if you need to set up
a new project or a new suite of projects
to use or you have new developers coming
in whatever you're easily able to use
the budget API to kind of put automatic
budgets on that without having to worry
about doing it manually right so super
super helpful especially when you get
into more complex project configurations
so go check that out as well lots of
cool things offered by cloud run and
budget but let's take the conversation
over to Ray and talk a lot more about
what the end and Java experience looks
like on Google Cloud
[Music]
ray thank you so much for joining us
today first things first who are you and
what do you do yeah hello thanks for
having me on the podcast my name is
Radian and I'm a developer advocate at
Google cloud and I focus a lot on the
Java developers in Java community and
you know I try to bring some of the
technology that we have from TCP to Java
developers and the other side of things
I try to do is of course to make our
platform run better for the Java
applications you know to be easier to be
used by Java developers out there so I
guess one of the first interesting
questions I have out of that is
obviously Java has been around for a
long time
Java has actually been around longer
than the cloud probably right yeah I
think I started professionally with the
Java the almond maybe back in 2003 2004
or something like that as being a while
since so you know people have been using
it to write their applications in around
the earth enterprise systems the first
public implementation of java 1.0 was in
1995 so it sounds like you know you've
been working with it since before the
cloud and obviously have a lot of
expertise in it
my first question kind of comes down to
what's different about Java in the cloud
well it depends on how you want to run a
tanto what are this years trying to
solve you know I think that from my
language perspective it's just another
programming language but when you are
running the application I mean largely
can be pretty much the same I guess if
you are accustomed to running your
application via a an application server
or a web application server it's pretty
much the same thing II just you know you
had the running on your machine on
somebody else's machine or on a machine
in the cloud
they are just processes up gets wrong so
I've also read there's this new
announcement for App Engine standard
right yeah so for App Engine that they
say platform as a service so depends on
you know what you're looking for if you
know you want to run some existing apps
you with the existing ways you can do
that with just you know cloud
infrastructure running with VMs and set
up your networking on the other extreme
of course is to be hands-off on all of
those things and give us the application
that you want to run and you know
platform as a service we will be able to
provision you know the resources for you
the load balancer for you even keeping
the wrong time up to date for you as
well with App Engine it can also
automatically scale your application
out to as many instances as you need or
they can actually just reduce the
instances down to zero if nobody is
using the application and this will give
you the elasticity that you might be
looking for for certain workload so I
mentioned before that I'm not as
familiar with Java and certainly haven't
dealt with it in a while but Java you
know kind of running in the JVM it's
kind of a long-running instance usually
pretty hefty workloads how does that
compare to something like you just said
an app engine when you're really working
on it server lessly
yeah so I think that there are many
different forms of the app is just
another language but you know certainly
I think traditionally people may be
running their application in a hefty
application server traditionally in the
very long time ago I think my
application server may start in 30
minutes like a whole update process
could be an entire night but that's not
the case anymore I mean it's being a
long time since I had to do that for
example the community has progressed so
much now that you know there are a lot
of the micro-services frameworks that
helps you to you know put up a lot
faster and focus on the things that you
want to do so for example one of the
most popular one is spring spring boot
this is pretty well known it's very very
popular right now and I see a lot of
adoption of a in production systems too
and you know from a micro service
perspective it give you everything you
need in case you'll start up your app
your services in matter of seconds as
opposed to minutes for that matter so
that really helps and then there are
definitely newer
frameworks I just came out maybe this
year and last year things like micron I
think work is in these new frameworks
they take on the challenge in different
ways for example in micronaut they try
to generate a lot of the code at the
compile time as opposed to a long time
and they can link them together very
easily and then you can just run them
very easily without having a lot of
additional overhead that you might infer
if you want to generate code at the
wrong time and Quercus is another new
framework from Red Hat primarily and the
only do they have pretty fast rate of
speed too
it allows you to use some of the
well-known standards you know IG APA and
CDI and a few other things for jax-rs
but they also focus on the ability to
make sure that you can potentially
compile this down into what we call
native image okay so to
it's actually possible to compile Java
code with grah VM native image down to
native binary and you know you can
actually start up your application
potentially in sub-second of course this
is really really new I don't know if I
could do this in production but you know
people have tried it and I think all of
the frameworks the ones that I all
missions all have some level of support
Mike Renaud since they're all pretty
much generated at compile time all of
these things can be compiled down to
native image as well quark is has a
support by default and spring booth I
was at the conference here at devoxx
Belgium just this week and you know I
saw a demo of spring booth that was also
being compiled down to native image and
that also starts something sub-second as
well so I think the community is really
moving forward but even without this you
know I think that couple of seconds I
think that's pretty ok even sometimes I
see heavier workload that the promise of
the service to me is not really just
about the startup speed right because
you know of this environment like say
App Engine you can also specify minimum
instances in the whether you want to
auto scale so it's not absolutely
necessary for you to have like super
fast startup time what is key here to me
is that you don't have to manage
anything that to me is really nice right
so for example rather than spending a
lot of the time to figure out how to
create a potentially compliant
infrastructure I can run your workload
and this can take you know month of work
just to figure out what the production
environment looks like and how that
actually work App Engine is already
production already environment and you
can just give us your file which is how
most people you know produce your
application artifacts just give us a jar
and we can just deploy that into App
Engine and everything gets bootstrapped
and it just starts to serve so that's
pretty cool so I want to come back to
some of the points you actually just
mentioned but let's start with you know
kind of taking a jar file and sending it
to App Engine now the latest update for
App Engine is that it supports Java 11
first of all what does that bring that
App Engine didn't have for Java before
well so I think there are two primary
things first of all is that it has the
new language support so there are new
your language support in Java 11 that's
not otherwise here in Java 8 but I think
the more interesting perspective would
be the second part which is that
traditionally App Engine takes a war
file
and that they say web application the
package where you know you package you
structure application differently so
that you can run this in an app server
like Tomcat with jetty or you know
something else but as the community
progresses right as new frameworks come
up and being adaptive even more popular
you know people don't really want to
configure their app server anymore and
they just want to be the jar file that
just runs so locally just say Java that
jar and the application starts just fine
and you don't have to set up any other
additional components except for your
JVM then you're up and running so in App
Engine Java 11 we switched the packaging
format from war to jars to through this
use case where I do see a lot of people
do and you can basically deploy any jar
file now I still a startup and listen to
the port right so now you get a little
bit more flexibility because you don't
have to have that web application
framework around it plus sounds like
it's a little bit less overhead to get a
jar up and running an app engine it's a
lot easier to do but you know there's
still a application framework Val you
might want to use you can of course make
your application without any framework
but that could be potentially off work
and of course if you do it that way the
starless speed is even gonna be faster
but if you want the convenience I think
overwhelmingly people may still choose
to use a framework I think what is
really nice is that now you can use any
framework that you want and expecting
the same result and you don't have to
modify a lot of code or any code to be
able to run it in App Engine so for
example in the past maybe trying to
deploy a spring booth application into
App Engine Java 8 the previous version
and you have to you know understand how
to convert that jar file that you're
really producing into a war file with
the right structure which are by 11
runtime you don't have to do that
anymore and I have seen a lot of people
getting into trouble and it's hard to
you know understand what would it take
to you know cover this package into your
package that the previous version can
run
now once the previous version I really
mean that we are actually having both
versions running at the same time so if
you're on Java 8 and if you are
accustomed to the war packaging it
continues to use that they issue it but
if you want to try to our application
deployment they cannot need to use the
new runtime the Java runtime instead and
like you mentioned earlier you kind of
have your choice of framework
or none if you wanted to do that way but
that obviously wouldn't be best
practices in spring boot was a big
framework that you kind of mentioned as
a popular example so what does spring
boot bring to Java so spring Buddhists a
really nice framework where you know
spring has been around for a very long
time don't even remember what year that
was when they first started spring boot
can be traced back to its humble
beginnings in 2002 and the transition
way it was configured through you know a
lot of XML and when spring boot came
along then the configuration became a
little bit more automatic and they focus
on I would say convention over
configuration as opposed to in the past
where we may end up with a giant XML
file that just determines how you can
run and serve one endpoint in spring
boot you just create a class go to
controller
rest controller annotation to it and
then you create the method in at a
kidnapping or post mapping depending on
their operation you want to handle and
now if you go it takes maybe I don't
know five lines of code to serve an
endpoint today and everything can get
started very easily my good friend Josh
alone from pivot oh he always shows you
know how to get started he's got oh the
best videos I think online teaching
people how to do this and his favorite
is of course I start out spring I oh you
can go to that site and you can
bootstrap a spring boot application
really really easily and you can also
add GCC support from start spring i/o so
in our site you can say I want to create
a web application you just add a web
component to it or you can add a bunch
of other components and it'll just
automatically configure your app we
click on download and it generates the
zip file and you unpack it you're ready
to go so that lets you start integrating
with other GCC products a lot easier for
spring boots specifically we have a
project called spring cloud ccp so when
you generate that app or when you're
configuring a spring boot app you can
add the spring cloud GCP component to it
this project has been created by the
couch Java team here in New York and
once you add this the starter to it we
have a bunch of integrations with GCP
services right so if you are already
using spring boot you can add this
Google cloud starter into your
application then you can choose what
services you want to integrate with so
for example if you want to use something
data store right you have the option of
using a data store API directly or if
you want something more you know close
to what you're doing with spring data
where you have object relational mapping
layer on top of your application so you
can deal with you know pojos or plain
old java objects in persisting that into
the database with spring data data store
you will be able to do exactly the same
thing and I show this in my demo quite a
bit in the process of using spring data
for the a store is exactly the same as
you would with another sequel pasty
restore that's supported by spring data
GPA similarly we have support for
spanner too so if you don't want to use
the spanner raw API then you can use in
data for spanner
yeah the process is exactly the same you
write the poggio and notate it with the
right annotations and you implement the
repository interface or you see
extending the repository interface and
within a few lines of code you'll be
able to have a crowd acess to the data
store itself so it makes the whole
process very very easy in industry in
through theta axis I think that more
importantly especially now with all the
micro services architecture we're
creating more and more small services
that's you know come potentially calling
services calling other services as well
you cannot need to know and understand
how the request kind of flows through
you know from one service to another and
for this people to try to implement
teachability tracer and in spring boot
there's a really you should really trace
your beauty you get this tracer by
adding a starter configuration called
spring cloud flute okay and as soon as
you add this starter without changing
any of your code you get you should
really tracing across but micro services
and for us for example for spring cloud
GCP you can also add our starter which
will get you basically uses the same
spring cloud sleuth pipeline or the
plumbing of sprinkles Luth it actually
pulls in spring cloth for that matter so
you configure your application exactly
the same way that you would as there any
other spring cloud application but with
our addition oh the traces will
automatically flow to start driver trace
right so you don't have to change any
code so your application becomes pretty
much agnostic to the environment that
you want to run or to back in technology
that you want to integrate with because
in
all these starters when you are adding
capabilities you don't actually have to
change your code in most cases same
thing with logging so if you want to log
to start rather logging depends on your
environment if you are in Crippen
Eddie's you have two options you know
you just do the regular logger which
will just be plain text however because
the log message is not structured so the
logger on the side driver-side wouldn't
be able to parse your message and
understand you know that the different
structure so for example if you actually
add a sprinkle sleuth to your
application or our starter to your
application every log message that you
print out will be associated with the
trace ID right because the trace ID came
through from another micro service to
yours potentially and you propagate the
same trace ID downstream to another
service and when we put these log
messages the Valk lines are actually
associated with the trace ID what that
means is that given the trace ID you
could potentially go back to the login
console you can type in the trace ID you
can see all the log messages associated
with that particular request however we
just printed out as plain text there's
no way for us to parse it inputting a
special field so we can query it better
another mode of doing this is to output
the log as JSON format okay so you can
print your log message in a structured
JSON format and in this Jason payload
the potentially is a attribute code the
trace ID and you gotta put the right
trace ID in there but that's a lot of
work to do this yourself so again with
the screen call TCP integration what
were able to do is to automatically
generate this JSON payload for you and
when you use the logger and tracer
together the result is really nice what
you get is for example you can see the
disability trace instead of a trace you
can see what other services it called in
this tree structure and for every one of
these span for every one of these calls
you can say show logs and you can
actually can see the log messages
associated with that particular request
for that particular call it's super
super useful when it becomes to you know
you need to troubleshoot some issues you
have the trace ID where you knows the
issues you go back to your console and
you open up the request that has the
issue and now you can clicking and see
Sally what happen with spring boot it's
pretty easy to get a Java app up and
running but
really you want spring cloud to take
advantage of all the cloudy atmosphere
stuff that you can use to really kind of
build debug and integrate your java app
with the rest of the cloud right and
when you say spring colleting spring
cloudy generates an umbrella project
from from spring so they include a lot
of things and yeah so I I think that's
spring cloud in general that umbrella
project helps you to run applications in
a cloud but spring cloud GCP
particularly gives you the options of
integrating a lot of these features
directly with Google cloud services and
I think that the end result is that when
you write your application you focus on
the app when you are ready to add
capabilities you can add these
additional dependencies so that without
having to change a lot of your app or
without having to changing anything you
get these capabilities added to your app
automatically and now you're ready to
leverage the cloud native services
easier and faster without having to
worry about the yahshua implementation
of that what if you're kind of working
with an older java application and you
want to migrate that to the cloud
instead right so if you're using like
hibernate or something of that nature
what changes do you need to make to get
that up and running well so hibernate
has been around for a long time and it's
still being used a lot right so it's not
necessarily odor but everybody who is
using emulation or database is probably
gonna be using hibernate you know
somewhere in their stack or maybe they
just use JDBC driver but you can
continue to use hibernate of course you
know talking to our databases for
example we can talk to our secret
databases on cloud sequel we support
Postgres in my sequence so that should
be pretty easy to get started with but
if you wanna adopt something like cloud
spanner it is a relational database that
kind of spans across the multiple
regions and potentially across the world
with consistency which is absolutely
amazing but will you spanner you have a
couple of choices right it is recently
they have released a open-source JDBC
driver where you can just use the
regular you know Chile BC connections
and you can do recent write operations
through to the BC however you follow use
it with hibernate what is special about
this is hibernate will need to
understand how to talk to the backend
sequel databases because every single
database may have a slightly different
way of communicating right they have
different secret I likes so the team
actually has created a hibernate dialect
for spanner
and at the time of this recording this
is steel beta I don't know 100 G a I
heard this gonna be pretty soon so it's
definitely coming soon but time of the
recording right now you can actually
give it a try that's in beta right now
so what that means is that you know it's
not just there to work with existing
applications as using hibernate but also
things like running anything with micro
profile that uses JPA that uses
hibernate behind the scenes you can
actually integrate that with cloud
spanner to to take advantage of this
really awesome database architecture
that Google has or if you're using
something like Quercus you can also use
carcass with APA with hibernate behind
the scenes and then you can use the
hibernate dial like for spanner to
communicate and do crack operations with
spanner as well so regardless of the
frameworks that you're using you still
have a good way to access you know
basically Google's databases but still
being able to run your java code in
whatever way you mentioned like you said
kubernetes you can run it on App Engine
you can run it in a more traditional
compute engine instance you have all
those options or even if you're um
praying you can running anywhere because
I think all of these services are just
api's so if you have a fast enough
internet you should be able to run it
anywhere that you want and still being
able to authenticate and get access to
the database if you want to but one of
the nice points you mentioned is that by
putting it in the cloud you're also able
to take advantage of all the ops things
you can do with it right logging
monitoring debugging tracing all these
things yet are not as easily done in
some environments oh absolutely
I think GCP next San Francisco I did a
hog that kinda showed how everything
worked together so you're not talk I
showed you know how do you get started
with spring cloud GCP with spring boot
how do you add some of these data access
options with spring data spend on with
the other store and then you can add
trace and logging and a bunch of other
capabilities for your app in a chest a
matter of picking what the runtime
environment is and you can continue eyes
your app for example and the thing also
have created something called jib GI B
and this is a really really easy way for
example to containerize your java
application producing a container image
without you having to write a docker
file I have to say docker file you know
everyone can write a doctor files right
but to write it correctly it can be
somewhat challenging you have to follow
many best
this is so with chip we actually
implemented some of these best practices
and they can produce a very efficient
container image without you having to
ever write a line of docker file and
then you can push this image to our
content registry or another registry
which we ever thought you need to push
to and you can deploy that container to
the kubernetes environment or wrong
environment for that matter and you can
integrate Jib with whatever your build
process is right so if you're using like
great or maven or something it's very
easy to just containerize it and then
ship it that's right yeah cheap supports
that both maven great Oh two of the most
popular key to us right now
so from code to deployment it sounds
like there's kind of integration points
throughout the entire stack of Java
development that you know kind of are
dressed by different parts of Google
Cloud we just talked about the build we
just talked about the framework that's
supported we talked about the kind of
the operations piece with logging and
monitoring what about the IDE I think
that recently the team has released the
cloud code and cloud close is the plugin
that you can add to your IDE
specifically IntelliJ or vs code so for
example in the IDE you can create a new
sprinkler application and from the IDE
you can potentially add app engine
support so you know directly from the
IDE you will be able to add whatever
that's necessary to deploy to App Engine
without ever having to go back to the
show in cloud code also have the
capability of connecting to a kubernetes
cluster so from cloud code they give you
quite a few I really nice in
auto-completion seen everything so that
when you're editing the mo files
specific to Google Cloud you can get
auto completion which is super awesome I
show this in my presentations in the
talks all the time and cool members how
to write complicated yellow file right
but with some editors support it becomes
fairly easy and potentially from the IDE
what you can do is to just post wrap a
brand new application and then he
actually has a built-in template shows
you how to create a spring pool
application with the necessary
kubernetes components accommodates files
you need to take advantage of this
plugin so for example in a typical
criminales development cycle you would
need to create the app you need to you
know you strip to create a container
image and then you have to write your
communities and manifest the deployment
demo files for it
and then if you change some code you
have to recreate the image and then you
know potentially update the manifest and
then reposting to a community
environment whether it's on your machine
like mini cube or remotely in kubernetes
cluster and then you maybe test it out a
little bit and then if you found another
issue you have to redo this cycle again
and there's a really nice tool called
scaffold say coming line tool now you
can use that basically automates this
development cycle for you so that
whenever you change some code it can
automatically refresh the image and then
automatically pushing that image to the
right registry and then automatically
redeploy the application for you and
from your console from your computer
without having to connect remotely
yourself you will actually output the
log for you so it feels like you're
running your app locally even though
it's actually running a remote container
in a criminal's cluster somewhere or in
your mini cube in cloud code can
integrate with scaffold really well so
if you add a scaffold to your
application your IDE will say hey do you
want to add scaffold support and
IntelliJ for example it will add a
little ROM button that's specifically
designed to run in kubernetes in a
continuous deployment mode and you know
you continue your regular editing cycle
and once you save the file you will
recompile and recreate the image and
redeploy it for you it's really neat and
the team actually went even a step
further by adding the debugging support
too so like if we run applications
locally we can attach the debugger so
that you can step through the code you
can add a breakpoint in your code so you
can add a debugging point and you can
step through the code to see what's
going on if you don't do that in the
canadiens environment parent involvement
and of course then you can use cloud
code with a scaffold in the debugging
mode and what I will do is automatically
enable debugging support in your app and
automatically attach the debugger to
this remote process that's running
kubernetes cluster and in your IDE
you will be able to debug this
application even if it's not running on
your local machine and this whole
process is seamless
which is super super neat a great place
for people to get started would be cloud
code because all of the integrations
that really make the entire development
process a lot easier yeah yeah so for
example if you want to also add Google
cloud services even though using spring
you're not using spring cloud GCP and
you want to add some client libraries
in cloud code there is also a option for
you to connect to a service and from the
UI it'll allow you to you know determine
what service you want to use and once
you select it you will enable the API
for you which a lot of people forget to
do right if you want to use any API
services you have to go in able the API
the idea why I should kill you do you
want to angle this API it will generate
the service account key for you as well
and then you will automatically add the
client library to your maven work widow
boot so you can very easily add
additional capabilities to your
application that sounds pretty
impressive because it sounds like it
really is designed to take care of as
much as possible for you because it
wants to get you to the point where
you're just worrying about the code all
of the pipe lines all the work that you
need to do and even as much as
integrating basically the remote
debugging all of its right there yeah
and of course since you mentioned
debugging I think there's another thing
that a lot of people don't know about I
do this all the time I ask people like
who are brave enough to attach the real
debugger to your production workload and
debug your application right or even in
staging environment they will be pretty
difficult to do mostly because when they
request coming people have to wait for
you to step through the code so I'm
Google actually you have another
debugger it's called cloud debugger and
the difference here is that for cloudy
bugger what you do is you added cloud
debugger agent to your application and
it will automatically connect to our
debugger console and from there in the
console you can potentially upload your
code or a serial code already if it's
really good repository that we have
access to if you give us the permission
to do it we can automatically pull down
the code or you can just upload the code
that you want to debug and email console
you can add a snapshot point as opposed
to a break point and as somebody flows
through that flow that you're trying to
debug will capture a snapshot of the
state of that moment in time and then
you can inspect the values and
potentially the co stack of what
actually happened without stopping the
world so the user is not being affected
by this but you are still able to see
the relevant data that you need and
what's funny is that the idea of join
talk with Robert pubis another cloud da
he actually focuses on spanner but we
did a troubleshooting talk in the past
and he made a joke like if you really
want to troubleshoot a production
environment this is how he does it he
does a binary log the
so played us and I think I do the same
thing to is you know if something really
doesn't work out you need to see what is
actually happening you probably want to
add a lock message somewhere right
because in the app don't usually have
all the locks that we need but then you
add a lock to the top you know at the
beginning and you add a lot to the very
end if the code doesn't reach the very
end you add a login support in between
right very familiar with that method you
know print one print to print three
print four and then you're just looking
through streams and numbers like oh I
see the code stopped at 37 so let's work
there exactly however if you had to you
a figure out where to add all these 37
things to log every time you change the
code you have to do another deployment
if you're lucky you can get it through
in minutes but I think in most of the
systems you know you could have to wait
hours before anything gets deployed so
with the debugger you can also add log
statements and you will add log
statements to your application in real
time without you having to do anything
addition so you don't have to redeploy
or anything like that and it also does
not affect the state of your app well
not actually modifying your code or also
not modifying your application or just
adding these interceptors these hooks so
that we know when you pass through
certain lines we will print out some log
messages for you right so pretty awesome
tool that very few people know about
sounds like it's an amazing way to
actually debug in a production
environment with very minimal impact to
the user rights without a pen so because
in production environment most people
may not actually want you know anybody
to just go in and you know point out
anything they want or its to see any of
the data right so I think that's a real
concern so this is really just for break
glass type of scenario for specially
authorized users to be able to do this
and of course you can lock down who can
do this right you can disable this by
default in only way absolutely need
actually I think more better use cases
probably like even staging or some
higher environment before you can get to
production you know during the the QA
test for the UAT test somewhere the
issue occurred you know of course will
say what's on my machine but you never
know what the user entered right and you
know in staging environment whatever
that UAT tester may have done it will be
very easy to understand what actually
happened I think a lot of people are
kind of afraid to get this into
production in most cases but everything
can be locked down so that's the good
news
yeah I'm convinced that if you just
label a server production that
automatically makes it buggy or somehow
you see all this in the areas that you
never seen before right who would've
thought this is what people have done
this actually happened to me once where
I had a small application a demo app and
every time I demo it it was fine when a
product manager was on stage demoing
this app it erode out I was like what
happened what just happened here and I
couldn't figure this out until I
actually went to the instance and use
this computer retrigger this and you
know reproduce it and then use the
debugger to figure out okay so the app
ask you for the name and the message and
the person did not enter the name and of
course that did not have arrow caching
for this one because it's the demo app
could have known right it says very
clearly interview in the end but who
knew and this was a real scenario for a
very small use case and it definitely
helped me and this actually turn into a
pretty fun talk as well users always
find fun ways to kind of interact with
your application in a way that you
wouldn't have expected right I mean if
you're asking to enter a name you expect
them to enter a name but you can't
guarantee they will exactly exactly
all right well I think we are just about
out of time but before we go ray is
there anything upcoming that you're
excited to talk about or any conferences
you'll be going to so this is the end of
the year and I'm very happy that I don't
have much going on for the rest of the
year but you know there's definitely
many other Java conferences out there
this very very active and I try to be in
person for many of them so that I can
meet and chat with you know the Java
developers so if you happen to hand some
of the Java conferences or the local
Java user groups let me know and I look
forward to be able to meet all of you
out there in person because I love to
talk to people in person as well awesome
and we'll make sure to include a couple
of key links in the show notes just for
people who are interested in trying out
some of the things that we talked about
here today but ray thank you so much for
joining us and hopefully we get a chance
to chat again soon all right thank you
for having me
thanks so much to Ray for coming in and
talking about Java I haven't used Java
for quite some time in any more than
just kind of
with a few things so it was really
exciting to hear about all the new
things he was also on the podcast quite
a while ago maybe two or three years ago
talking a little bit more about Java so
if that's something that is interesting
do you definitely recommend going to
check that out and hearing a bit more
about how it's probably changed or just
stay tuned with all the cool new Java
stuff speaking of which we've got our
question of the week
so the question of the week is how do i
docker eyes my java app right so I've
used plenty of docker files but it's
usually copied and pasted from the base
template and then slight modifications
they can get pretty complex and pretty
unwieldy so the answer to this question
is a [ __ ] and jib is built to kind of
integrate with your current Java
development workflow and help you build
your docker files without needing to
kind of get into the complexity of them
so the idea is that you basically just
kind of put it in a configuration if
you're using maven or Gradle it's pretty
simple or you can just use it by itself
and then you just point to a place to
host your actual docker file and from
there you're good to go it's really
really simple to set up and actually
there's a fun little video that just got
published that shows you how to use it
and then links over to the official
documentation so you go check that out
but it's a pretty simple process and I
think it's really valuable for being
able to containerize and deploy your
java application without having to worry
about what's going on right without
having to worry about all the
configuration management it's just so
much more easy to put together a docker
file based on what your Java app is and
then move along right focus on the
actual part that matters which is your
code so check out the video definitely
check out jib on github and then if it's
interesting give it a shot see what you
can do with it and see how it can kind
of make that whole process a lot easier
that's awesome this week I'm spending
time playing video games with my dog
what about you
what do you up to so this week is gonna
be a busy week because we've got lots of
events happening right now we've got
Google cloud next over in London as well
as cube con and cloud native Connor
happening right about now so I can
imagine it's going to be a pretty busy
week we've got lots of people out in
travelling I've opted to kind of stay
behind in the Bay Area and get some work
done so hopefully I'll be able to do
that but there will be lots of exciting
announcements coming out from those
videos interviews all sorts of things so
definitely stay tuned for the next
week's episode because I'm sure will be
recapping some of that as well as
checking out the Google cloud blog and
the Google cloud YouTube channel because
there's going to be probably a ton of
stuff coming out from those definitely
excited to see what comes out of it well
that's gonna wrap it up for us so thank
you all for listening and we will see
you all next week
[Music]
I really should have just done the
podcast with myself as two people
something like hey Marc tell me more
about how did yous jib to docker as my
Java app well mark you can do or I could
use Robo Mandel I think we may be played
out rubber band Oh we'll see I'm so sad
to hear that you feel this way
it's hard being an ionic clone of a past
host just give me one more chance and I
promise I won't let you down